- I know that whenever you cook sometimes,
you're a fabulous cook.
She is, I've gone over to
her house, she'd make stuff.
(audience cheering)
And she gives you wine, it's
the most amazing experience.
But one thing I found out, actually,
was the fact that when,
he cooks sometimes, right?
Garth cooks sometimes?
- He does, yes.
- Okay, and he has, he's like
very perfectionist, right?
He's legit pretty good, right?
- He's pretty good, I
wouldn't say perfectionist.
He doesn't follow a recipe.
He's pretty much like,
will throw things together
that maybe go together, and
then he thinks it's fabulous,
and takes a picture of it.
(laughing)
I call him Gartha Stewart.
He's very proud.
- That's what I was tryna--
I love that you call him Gartha Stewart.
- He's very pressed, like
look a made this sandwich,
I took a picture of it.
I'm like that's awesome, hunny.
- And you're like, meanwhile you're like,
look I have a cooking
show and I'm badass at it.
- I'll be like can you
open this jar of pickles?
Well I have my own cooking show.
I'm like really, seriously?
(laughing)
- Stay in your lane, Gartha!
No, I just found that
amazing, I found that amazing.